what I want to do in this video is
introduce you to a for loop and I'm
we're going to do this by writing a
little program that calculates the
factorial of a number in case you don't
remember what a factorial of a number
does if I were to tell you what one
factorial you normally write it you
normally write it as one and then an
exclamation mark like that it literally
just means well that will just evaluate
to one if you say two factorial that's
going to be equal to two times one if
you say three factorial 3 factorial
that's going to be equal to 3 times 2
times times 1 and which is going to be
equal to 6 and so if you have any number
of factorial is just going to be that
number times one number less than that
times one number less than that all the
way down to one so with that out of the
way let's implement our factorial
program and the way I'm going to do it
is it's going to take an input from the
user it's going to prompt the user to to
put a number that they want to take the
factorial of and then it's going to
calculate the factorial and so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to use a
function that Python provides for us and
I'm using Python 2 in this video you
will do it so you'd have to do it
slightly different actually I'll talk
about that in a second if you were using
Python 3 Python 2 is what most of most
implementations of Python are are
built-in at the time of this video but
there is a Python 3 out there that's
kind of a newer version I clarify that
about a bit in a in a future video but
anyway we're going to take an input from
the user and we're going to prompt them
with a message and we're going to say
enter a non-negative integer integer to
take the factorial of to take the
factorial of and just so that we get
familiarize ourselves with functions and
all we're passing an argument to the
function and the argument that we're
passing to the function to the input
function right over here is a string and
string sounds like a very complicated
thing but it really is just a string of
characters you can view it as a bunch of
text and it will present this text to
the user and it'll give them a little
input box the user will put something in
that input box it will evaluate within
that input box and then you could either
view it as have the variable
number refer to it or put it in the
variable number depending on how you
want to visualize depending on how you
want to visualize a variable if you're
using Python three if you're using
Python three you'll want to call eval on
what's returned from this function this
is if you're doing Python three I'm
running Python two right now and if you
want to if you want to do it exactly the
way I'm doing it I'm using the PI
scriptor IDE integrated development
environment it's free open-source
project on a on a PC but there's many
many ways that you can edit Python you
could really just do it on any any text
editor so anyway so so far all we've
done is we've taken input from the user
and we're putting it in the variable
number and what's really cool about
python is we can just run this program
as is and just see what happens so let's
do that I'm going to save it and I'm
going to run it this little play button
runs it in this IDE and just like we
said it prompts the user enter a
non-negative integer to take the
factorial of so I don't know let me type
in 10 and I type and I'll type okay
nothing happened well of course nothing
happened because I didn't really tell
this to do anything but if we type in
number if we type in number we'll see
that it is now assigned to 10 the
variable is now referring to the number
10 so now we can use this number and
take the factorial of it so what I'm
going to do and we're going to do it
iteratively and we're going to talk more
about what that means in the future so
I'm going to define another variable
called product and I'm going to start
product at 1 and we're going to do is
we're going to start from 1 up to
whatever number this is and keep
multiplying the product by each
successively larger number so we're
going to start so I'm going to set up a
for loop here in the next video I'm
going to really step through exactly
what a for loop does but we're going to
within the for loop we're going to
define a variable I this is kind of a
classic variable to define in for loops
and that's what we're going to that
variable is going to keep incrementing
to larger and larger values as we go
through it so for I in range and for
loops are in Python are a little bit
different than if you were doing it in
JavaScript or Java and I'll do a future
video where we do
but range of number and just to
understand what range of number does is
it provides a list of numbers starting
with 0 up to 1 less than that number so
if we talk
so over here we already defined what
number is number is 10 so if I type in
range of 10 or let me do range of number
it gives me a list starting at 0 all the
way to 9 all the way to 1 less than 10
so that's the same thing as range of 10
and what this for loop does is it
assigns the I to each term of the
sequence so it starts with 1 or each
term of this list it starts with 1 and
then it'll it'll whatever you tell it to
do in the for loop with I is equal to 1
then it'll assign I to be one that I'm
sorry it'll start the start with I
equals 0 then it'll go to I equal 1 then
I equals 2 then I equals 3 so on and so
forth all the way until you've gone all
the way through all the way through the
list and so what we can do here what we
can do here is within the for loop
within the for loop we can redefine
product to be equal to the product the
former product so our new product is
going to be our old product x times and
I'm going to multiply it times I plus 1
times I plus 1 we're going to step
through it carefully in the next video
but I want to think about what it's
doing already so right when we start
let's say that let's say that number
ends up being let's say it number ends
up being 3 so product gets set to 1 and
we say for I in range and then if we do
range of 3 range of 3 then I is first
going to be 0
and so we're going to take our old
product so 1 times I plus 1 well I is
going to be 0 so 0 plus 1 is 1 so it's
going to be 1 times 1 is going to be 1
then we're going to assign I to be 1
this is what the for loop does it
iterates it keeps incrementing well it
doesn't always have to increment what
keeps changing the value of I as it goes
through this list and so the next time
around now product is 1 but now I is 1
so 1 plus 1 is 2 times 1 is now going to
be 2 and then it'll go it'll set I to be
2 so it's going to be 2 plus 1 tie
what product was from the last iteration
which was - and so it's going to be two
times three which is six and so when you
when we finally done with this for loop
inside of product or I guess we could
say product we'll be referring to the
actual factorial of the number inputted
so then we could say print print product
and in Python in this case right here
the interpreter knows to break out of
this for loop once it runs out of
numbers to assign I to so that's why it
doesn't run forever so let's see if
let's see if what we did here actually
actually works let's see if it actually
works so let me actually let me write it
like this so let's see if this thing
actually works so I'll save it and then
let me run it and so it's asking me
enter a non-negative integer to take the
factorial of so let's try with three
enter it gave me the right answer let's
try it again
let's try it again so enter a
non-negative integer to take the
factorial of I don't know let's let's
try something large ten it worked
assuming you could verify for the this
for yourself so we've done here is write
a very simple program but it already
does something neat it takes a factorial
of an arbitrary number in the next video
we're going to step through it much more
carefully in case this kind of confused
you what this for loop did so just just
hold with me for the next video and
watch that and that beg there's a little
bit more of a careful explanation